so if the alarm goes off please leave
the building in an orderly fashion
through the nearest fire
exit please use the fire exit through
the main doors of the hall or the exit
fire exit in the store room adjacent to
the stage the fire assembly point is the
island in front of the main entrance to
the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be live streamed please
switch off mobile phones or turn them to
silent please note that the toilet and
handwashing facilities are in the foyer
area members of the public there is
drinking water available near the main
doors into the Hall while you can of
course film or take photographs during
this meeting please note that this
should be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from seats
that have been reserved for
this can I please therefore ask if you
raise your hand clearly in the air if
you wish to take photographs or film
this
evening no one's indicated so that's
that please be upstanding members to
receive the chairman John councelor Jack
laurman Reverend Kim lepley and the
chief executive Jonathan
Stevenson
please upstanding members to receive the
oh done there I'm here
right invite Reverend Kim Kim lley to
say a few words of Prayer okay are they
allowed to sit down you want to sit down
you may yeah sit
down we sit in church to
[Music]
pray it is lovely to be with you again
this evening it's getting cold isn't it
getting cold and there's lots of trick
and treaters out there this evening so
uh it is a joy to be with you so uh as
we uh come to this meeting I'd like to
open it with with prayer so please do
join me if you so wish to let's
pray almighty God we bring before you
this evening the agenda for tonight's
meeting that we who have been entrusted
with the responsibility to govern and
make decisions for those who have
elected us that we are Guided by the
best of motives and with the interests
of all for the benefit of all give clear
Minds and the desire to hear all points
of you including those who may be
opposed to our own and for an openness
and respectful
debate make us gracious and courteous to
friend and opponent alike with a real
sense of working together for this
district and the areas that are
represented by each of our district
councilors heavenly father at the same
time we commend for your blessing the
work of of all the employees of Rochford
District Council who maintain Implement
and make possible the words that are
debated discussed and formed into
policy this we pray in jesus' name
amen if you know the words and would
like to join in I invite you now to join
me with the words of the prayer that
Jesus taught us the words of the family
prayer Our Father which chart in heaven
Hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done in earth as it is in
heaven give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses as we
forgive them that trespass against us
and lead us not into temptation but
Deliver Us from Evil for thine is the
kingdom the power and the glory forever
and ever ever
amen so this evening ladies and
gentlemen may God infold you in love
fill you with peace and Lead You In Hope
and the blessing of God Almighty the
Father the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit be with you and all whom you love
this night and forever more
amen thank you for your invitation Le
you're welcome St but I know you're very
thank you I will see you next time thank
you very much thank you God bless
[Music]
you members welcome to the to this this
evening's meeting um the first of
Council the first thing I would ask you
to do is if you would all please stand
so I can um we could be members I would
ask you to stand and join me in a moment
of reflection for all those of suffering
in the conflict in the Middle East and
in Ukraine
[Music]
please
thank
you right if we can commence the
meeting
agenda item one apologies for absence
members we have received apologies from
councelor Mrs Daniel Belton and
councelor Elliot Mason are there any
other apologies for
members now
received agenda item two minutes of the
last meeting held on the 7th of
September
2023 members are you happy for me to
sign the minutes of the meeting held on
the 7th of September 2023 Council V
wouldn't
thank you Mr chairman um in terms of
accuracy um I can't take issue on
accuracy but uh an amendment came
through yesterday um referring to item
160 paragraph 160 um and whilst I do not
take issue with the fact that uh some
conservative members left the meeting at
that time I do think that the minutes
and bear in mind that that part of it
was in the exempt part of the meeting uh
but I do think that the minutes as it's
being recorded openly should show
balance and reflect the fact that uh at
the time those members left the meeting
it was approaching 10:00 uh and uh uh
there was a 402 page report to consider
uh and the reason that those members
left was we felt that we could not do
duud J Justice uh to for that report uh
so I think there should just be balance
but I'm not taking issue with uh the
actual wording within the minutes but I
believe that part should be added just
to put it in within context please
chairman thank
you thank you counc w my only um
observation of that is is it would have
been fortunate I think had you that
comment been made before everybody left
so that there have been an understanding
of why people left it's all
retrospective in this
manner chairman if I may um I will
amplify it further by saying that
actually councelor uh Danielle Belton uh
councelor gadston and myself made some
quite strong speeches but they were in
the exempt part so um we did make our
reasons quite clear at the time but I
wasn't expecting the detail of those
speeches to be recorded so um I have to
say we did make our reasons quite clear
and I'm not asking for all of that to be
recorded in the minutes but just to be
reflect that there were reasons thank
you chairman thank you councelor
Hoy um might I suggest that the minutes
of this meeting will now reflect
councelor won's
concerns yeah we'll take that you happy
with that Mr W thank
you so are we happy having had that
conversation we're happy for me to sign
this uh the minutes agre agree thank
you right item three to receive
declarations sorry chairman um councelor
Mrs Christine Mason was indicating
chairman I did not see you I apologize
for that Mrs Mason if you'd like to make
your
point yes um whilst I accept the
accuracy to a degree of what council won
has said I think it is not totally
complete and I think if the record is
showing that they what he wants they
should also show that there was a member
briefing there were other conversations
with councilor won and other members of
the groups they were well aware and the
report was not 400 Pages it was about 24
the rest were appendices and they had
plenty of time to read it so I'd like
that put on the minute as well thank you
going forward thank
you thank you
[Music]
I got glaz could you just turn your sign
a little bit please because I got the
light shine I can't I do apologize I
just can't see it properly hello um my
feeling is
that we tried very hard that night to
explain that although some of our
members were at a briefing many of us
were not and the time period in which we
given the briefing and although one
though one may say there was only 21 21
page 25 Pages the appendices needed to
be read and completely understood before
we could comment so therefore to say
that 25 Pages was just a small report
that we could have gone through that
night was totally unrealistic in the
time period that we were given to do it
and I would also sorry chair I'd also
like it reflected that I think feel that
the original minute should be amended to
show the fact that we give plenty of
reasons why we did not continue with
that meeting we were there to try and
work with the opposition who did
everything that evening to block any of
our initiatives to support them thank
you well the minutes a reflection of
what we took at the time and this is all
retrospective so I'm not going to
suggest that we re we redo those minutes
under what you just said thank you we
now go on to item three to declare item
three to receive Declarations of
interest and at the moment there are no
Declarations of interest is any can step
down chairman with regards to the
planning uh item eight um I ought to
mention that I'm an Essex County
counselor and I do sit on the planning
committee at Essex than
C anybody else okay we move on item
four
item for announcements from the chairman
leader or head of paid Services um first
of all councelor John Mason do you wish
to make any
announcements no chair I have no
announcements this evening thank you for
the invitation right C Mr
Stevenson thank you chairman I've got no
announcements this evening than you but
then lad to item agenda item five public
questions and member questions on notice
[Music]
members do apologize I forgot me so I
have to do my announcements and I'm not
one to uh talk about me much as you
know so right let's start if I can find
them here we are right first of all um
thanks every so much I mean it's
hopefully a light light evening right I
want to bring to to just mention that uh
during the last or since the last
meeting I I um I attended the cost of
living event the by your side cost of
living event which was Pro organized to
provide a platform for dialogue IC
brought together experts local
businessmen and Community leaders to
offer support and advice on health and
being the cost of living which was open
to all and that I must say was excellent
for all those that attended I thought it
was a very good evening all day rsford
District Council also made a fair job
fair recognizing employment as a crucial
component of stable life this this event
aimed to connect job Seekers with local
employees boosting our local economy and
helping our residents secure miningful
employment again I was
impressed the Forget Me Not EV I
attended to forget me not of the mega
Center was another memoral occasion
quite sad in its way but I think they're
doing a grand job down at the mega
Center for people with dementia and and
that sort of loneliness and I thought
that was an excellent effort by all
those concerned and something we should
follow up
on and through this event to show
commitment support and and ensuring that
no one has forgotten it's a lovely day
um I also got involved well ATT the food
bank 10 year anniversary which was a a
significant Milestone acknowledging the
dedication hard work of all those
involved involved in this vital
service um I also had the privilege
attending the Lord Lieutenant's National
Honors seminar it was a great
opportunity to engage with fellow
leaders and discuss how we can further
serve our community and recognize those
who have made an exceptional
contribution to our to our district I
did leave my name on a table somewhere
just um right we did uh in this Hall we
had make your Market rail which was an
event designed excuse me to boost that
local econ eony and and support our
small businesses we encourage everybody
to shop locally and support our thriving
marketplaces I would like to extend a
heartfelt thank to two people in
particular and two people um as you I'm
sure you all know I had a quiz night in
here
upstairs and and it was in on behalf
scaf my my charity and it was a
fantastic evening more than I expected
and there was probably about 100 people
attended it was a marvelous Marv night
and the reason it was made the way it
was is because of two mainly two people
and that was counselor Joe mcferson and
counselor arur
Williams their performance was second to
none and I'm going to raise that as a
question because I tell you what you
were brilliant and I'm really really
want to make a mention of you two that
was professional it was fun it related
well the people in the the group and
above all we made 800 850 pound charity
money out of that 850 quid and I want to
run another one so if you're going for
it don't don't leave the town you know
so so I would like to run that was
brilliant and I've got to give you full
credit for all of that I mean Holly um
Holly boy my Civic officer joined in and
she was collecting raffle tickets and
sorting people out the door but to
believe you me it was those that
attended it was brilliant and thanks
again thanks ever so
much before I conclude I would like to
bring your attention to important
initiates my first is the Christmas card
competition open to all primary age
children who live or attend school in
our district who want to see the
creativity and talent of a young
resident showcased during the festive
season and the subject matter I I asked
for it to be is something like the
presence in the stocking around around
the fireplace you know something like
that you know it could be a kitten in
the sock or whatever but just a little
bit of a sort of thing for the kids to
get on with and I thought that would be
really nice as a Christmas card so if he
could encourage that I'd be grateful the
second is a citizen of the Year award
very important one we've got a lot of
brilliant people in this in this
district and this is an opportunity to
recognize and celebrate the outstanding
individuals who made a real difference
to our community and I encourage all of
you to nominate someone who you believe
deserves this honor and and I could
think of a few so and we can't un fely
put Jo or Arthur in because you're
members but uh seriously I think that if
you know people please put them up
because I mean I think it's an excellent
excellent idea so thank you for that
I've said enough well I've not said
enough but I've said enough for you to
listen to so um we'll move on so then we
go on to where are this
one I
[Music]
paper right agend right five public
questions of members questions or notice
members we have received one question on
notice from councelor Roger
cable C councelor cable can you please
read out your
[Music]
question thank you Mr chairman i' would
like to ask the executive lead member
for resources climate change and economy
to explain why the last climate
emergency committee meeting was held in
the middle of the afternoon thereby
excluding working counselors members of
the public from
attending I would now invite Deputy
leader councelor Michael ho to respond
to the
question thank you
chairman uh thank you councelor
Constable uh traditionally formal
council meetings as you suggest at this
Council have largely taken place in the
evenings however in this case the count
Pate emergency committee is a
subcommittee of the executive rather
than a full Council and although
not commonly but have in the past along
with working groups taken place during
the day and in addition I felt that
given the current climate emergency it
was important that the committee met as
a matter of urgency as an afternoon slot
was the only one available within the
time frame as the meetings are
accessible through the live stream and
subsequent recording held on YouTube and
I believe that committee had over 40
viewings and I last checked members of
the public and councilors have had good
opportunity to see the committee in
action future meetings are likely to
alternate between evenings and Day times
thank
[Music]
you think thank you councelor Hoy
councelor Council would you like to ask
a supplementary question at
all Yes it it's um it may be that they
the committee was viewed but I don't
feel that this the committee is being
taken seriously by the council when it
only lasted 11 minutes and the fact that
half the committee weren't able to
attend so therefore I think that I
should like some reassurance from
Council aoy that all committee meetings
are held in the evenings and not during
the day because that does exclude a lot
of people thank
you not question counc H do you wish to
make a
comment uh thank you chairman given that
the conservatives didn't really seem to
want the climate committee or or to
declare a climate emergency I I won't
answer that part of the question the the
meetings will take place when resources
allow them to take place I won't
guarantee they're in the
evenings working patterns nowadays are
such that councilors work in the
evenings as well as during the day and I
think if you you you do evenings to the
exclusion of the day or the day to
exclusion of the evenings certain
counselors will be excluded so we we
would carry on doing it the way we are
we would alternate
hopefully with the meetings as I've
suggested and
that counselors who wish to ask a
question still can ask a question they
don't have to be present and they can
ask a question or if they wish to see
what happens they can catch up on the
recorded stream on YouTube thank you
thank councel
H we now take item six agenda item six
minutes of the executive committee
meetings held between the period of the
22nd of August to the 4th of October are
these noted
members
right item seven agenda item seven
reports from the executive and
committees to
council members have one report from the
climate emergency committee the climate
emergency emergency progress report I
will now invite councelor Michael H to
introduce this report
report
thank you
chairman um the report is fairly lengthy
there are targets within this and there
are aspirations within this the it's
clearly only four to five months since
we took control of the administration
and this and the committee has only been
running since June so I think this is
quite
good so far I'll draw your attention to
a few points first of all I'd like
to go through the
um setting the sustainability strategy
targets for 23 24 on page
7.1.7 that's paragraph
five there are five items under there
and I'll briefly outline
them the first one is to secure funding
and assist in the delivery of
improvements for 50 Park
Homes this has started we have an
officer in place who is um arranging
this and and dealing with the paperwork
we've already had reports back from
Tower Park in holbridge that the work
has started and the provider the people
doing the work they've been very well
recommended and doing a good job um the
second one to submit an application of
phase two s pool that's been done we're
just waiting the outcome of that we're
not sure how long that will be
um the application to the phase 3 C of
public sector decarbonation scheme
that's to happen in
November the um fully costed business
case for replacement of diesel in the
council North feets with
hydrated I got that right FEG
oil was going to come to this meeting
but due to complexity of around that
that this is going to come to a later
meeting meeting now so our apologies for
that
and in December we'll present a fully
costed plan to set out the council's
path to Net Zero um in December as I
said that there are problems around this
a lot of this will take money and we
need to go into a budget or the mtfs
medium-term financial State strategy
which is why it can take a bit longer
than we hoped and is difficult
you'll also see on page this reg draph
which gives an intention of how we can
get to or close to zero
carbon which is on the wrong page sorry
about
that which is in paragraph
4.4 and we have to follow this I'd also
have a quick word about the scorecards
i' I've played quite a bit publicly and
within the meetings and in conversations
with officers about the climate plan
scorecard the latest ones have come out
and although on the face of it it's
quite disappointing we've gone from 3%
compliance to
133% that is quite a big big jump but
there are areas within that where we
just cannot score at all we can't score
anything on social housing we don't have
any so we can't score on it and it it it
will bring down our score because of the
other areas I'm be talking with Marcus
hton this week around the biodiversity
era for instance we were speaking
earlier and
and one area where you can score is for
not for having a non-use of Pete policy
we don't use Pete S tomorrow because we
probably haven't used it for 20 years
but we just don't have a policy on it so
we can't score on it so it's just things
like this to make sure
that we actually say what we do do
within the policy framework um happy to
take any questions on this as well thank
you any questions
members
can
um page
7.1.4 paragraph
3.4 of the 31 actions identified nine
have progressed and are on track nine
have not progressed and are not
completed or likely to be completed it
doesn't give any account for the 13 that
would make up the 31 I wonder if the
member could explain
[Music]
please I'm reading paragraph 3.4 you
said so we've got 9 98 and there 31 so
if you would like to look
at this is the sustainability
strategy which is on page
71 n and if you'd like
to look there you'll see it's it's done
on a red and a green basis and you can
see the rest there if you want to this
is the strategy which has improved I
think it was O October
22 around that time sorry my point is
there's no explanation in there if
you're going to if you're going to point
to 18 out 31 surely that should be
completed with the rest of the
information sorry I'm just going back I
was on the wrong page I'm going back to
the page again which I think was
7.14
sit
[Music]
down right so we have nine have
progressed and are on
track nine have progressed but have not
been completed or are likely to
completed with the original time scales
which means the others have not started
yet thank
you thank you that's helpful to
know ccor
cross thank you chairman um under 5.1 I
think it is um the use of hydrogenated
vegetable oils um I believe this
involves uh no uh conversion work at all
to diesel engine vehicles and hvo can be
mixed in any proportion with ordinary
diesel I'm just wondering why it's going
to take until 2024 before we start
implementing the use of hvo in our uh
diesel fleet we can start using it now
and and gain or rather have fewer CO2
emissions as a result thank
you do you have do you want to reply to
that thank you that would be my thoughts
entirely however we're constrained by
the budget for this year which has no
money in it to use the hydr
hydrogenated vegetable oils that it will
be at a cost to the council it cost more
than diesel cost therefore we need a
budget to do that so we are hopeful to
get a budget in for 23 24 if we can find
the money sooner and the council approve
of it we will do this sooner thank you
councelor Mrs
Mason thank you chair um I apologize if
I've missed this in the report um I have
gone through it but I I understood that
um councelor Mrs Belton and councelor
Hoy were going to visit the parish
councils just investigate possible joint
projects um so I'm I'm sorry if I've
missed it but I just wondered what the
update on that was please thank
you thank you councelor Mrs Mason you
haven't missed it because we haven't yet
done that I have spoken to a few Parish
councils which have started declaring
climate emergencies Ry has one um I
think H has done one I think I spoke to
councelor Doby there or spoken people
who spoken with her and I'm aware that
whole which has started the process of
declaring a climate emergency so I'll
take your point we will I will speak to
councelor belon and we will start
visiting the parish councils thank you
councelor
conable thank you Mr chairman on page
716 at the top that little um paragraph
there that says about annual cost
savings and to convert the fleet to
renewable diesel is listed as minus
94,000 so that's a cost to the Council
of 94,000 if I'm correct can the um
councelor confirm that is a correct
figure please counc
Hoy I'm happy to confirm that was a
correct figure at the time the report
was written if it's any different now
I'm sure Marcus hoton will advise us
thank
you counc
won thank you chairman um you can't be
surprised that in the supplementary
answer to the question uh made by my
colleague earlier that reference was
made about the conservative commitment
under this conservative Administration
up to may this year um you will note in
the report
2.1 uh that is all about the
achievements in the year 2022 to 23 so I
do take exception to the any suggestion
that this conservative administration at
the time were not committed to the
effects of climate change what I think
is rather nice across this chamber is
that there is across all 39 counselors a
unified commitment to doing everything
we can along with our officer team so it
is best when these things aren't
politicized but uh uh I'm not one to
miss an opportunity if someone else
chooses to make it political but Council
Hoy referred to the balance scorecard
the 3% and he has Amplified uh that line
um at
3.10 um he's gone some way to explain uh
what the balanced scorecard is but I
think what would be of Keener interest
to members is to understand what the
target is because I think we all accept
that there will be areas in there that
we can't comply but I think all these
things need to have specific and
measurable objectives and if the target
is I don't know
45% at least we can gauge how far we're
progressing towards that Target so my
question to council Hoy is can he set
some measurable objectives in terms of
what is going to be achieved thank you
chairman council do you wish to
reply thank you Council wion
um my comments earlier about the
declaring the climate emergency and the
climate committee I think I've given
lots of credit for the um sustainability
strategy which we are working to in this
report which was brought in under the
previous administration ation um if we
go to
um five again on page
7.17 we're talking about there to
present to the to the December 4 council
meeting a fully costly plan setting out
the council's path to carbon net zero
this would include our Targets on the
scorecard again I I the scorecard is
about what what we do it meas measures
the internally how we are we're doing
things what committees we've got what
policies we've got so it doesn't
actually necessarily mention car but it
just measures what we're doing to get
there but I think the thing I like about
it and why I want to follow it is it
measures us against other councils as
well so we can see how we How We Do
compared to other councils
and I think that's good to keep us on
our toes thank
you cancel cross you want uh thank you
chairman I'd just like to come back um
to uh the hvo question um there's no
conversion of diesel engine Vehicles
required so there's no cost involved
because there's no conversion to using
hvo it can be used in any proportion and
mixed with um ordinary diesel fossil
fuel diesel um it can be mixed in any
proportion there's no conversion
required there's a 10 to 15% premium in
the cost of the fuel but it's readily
available now and I'd just like to know
why we're not taking advantage of it now
and saving CO2 emissions thank
[Music]
you thank you counc cross um I think
it's already been identified on the
report that the additional cost would be
94,000 for using this I know it doesn't
sound very much but there is no budget
for 94,000 as we stand we have to have
this approved within the budget for next
year or somehow find the money this year
from somewhere else um that's why it's
not in their own yes yes we can and I
spoken we could put we could mix it with
the diesel we have in our tanks already
um that's not a problem but whatever we
do will be a cost the report which comes
back to this committee once we work
through that will allow the council to
decide whether it wants to do 10% 20%
50% or 100% whether they want to start
this year because we might find some
money this year or whether it's going to
be put back to 23 24 because we will
find the budget
then give I think Marcus wants to speak
I was gonna give the opportunity for
Marcus Hain to speak
thank you members um so it's
a thank you for remind me um it's
uh it is fairly simplistic that that the
existing Fleet can use the hvo um one of
the things of course you have consider
is the purchase of the hvo it can't be
bought from from your standard pumps and
so it's only very recently that we've
actually had a fuel Depot reinstalled uh
down at South Street so until uh say a
month ago we could even consider running
the fleet on hvo because there wasn't a
fuel tank as such that it could be
delivered to so it's not up till then
our Fleek were actually purchasing off
the four cult locally the diesel so
there is a um to consider the 10 15%
cost margin is on again for C costs but
we are purchasing the field as
considerably lower cost the diesel at
lower cost than that whereas the hvo
costs do not come down comparatively so
so there is
a ratio between the two to consider the
business case will be coming forward so
I agree it can be done it just it is a
cost of the council approximately around
£100,000 a year but we allow members to
decide on doing so but there is a
premium to this there's also question
around Providence that whereas that's
why we stored the um report we just want
to be absolutely sure on the um claims
on the 9% reduction in sort of CO2 um
sort of carbon impact that's caused by
um converting to biodiesel um some of
the sources are more questionable than
others so interestingly uh even the uh
sort of central government departments
have a different view so the environment
agency will not be converting to hvo but
def will do so so there there's a
there's a Divergence of views even
within central government about whether
this is a an acceptable route or not an
acceptable route so we're just ging some
um Clarity over that before the report
comes forward and ensuring the
Providence of what we actually recommend
purchasing uh is actually accurate
because there are cheaper sources of hvo
that perhaps The Proven is is more
questionable so we just want to be
absolutely accurate before we bring the
report forward some have gone I think
quite quickly down this route but my
concern is that actually some of the
provence of this and of the reliability
to statistics that have been claimed
against this are not as accurate as
first that we're led to believe but that
will be coming forthcoming in the report
thank
[Music]
you
you wish
this can I just update um that we
started a project with a seller which is
as you know the association of South
essic local authorities and because
every local Authority has exactly the
same issue Katherine Hutchin from um car
point the chief executive has said that
we should start looking at doing bulk
purchasing for all six local authorities
in South Essex that might bring the 15%
premium down to two or 3% so we've act
actioned that and what we're doing is
we're cating the data from each of the
six burs in South Essex to see if we can
get rather than 250,000 lers of
biodiesel green diesel we can purchase a
million liters or 1.2 million liters
that way we get the bolt savings and
that takes a pressure of the financial
constraints because it is a 15% premium
which does flex with the market but that
project is activated today and we're
cating information as an a seller group
procurement
exercise members I think we've discussed
it okay I'll give you one
mrd thank you chairman I'm scaring this
report looking for good things in it and
I think I found maybe one so let know
this is achieved on
7.1.2 right the top of the page where
it's the business
travel now I know 2021 nobody went
anywhere but we seems to have reduced
their cost by half from 1819 to 1920 I
can sort of understand how we've
achieved this but how can we work make
this better is any given any thought to
this councelor Mrs
Wilson thank you chair um just to
clarify sorry I'm going back a question
to Marcus if that's okay chair um just
to clarify the annual cost saving which
we know is going to cost us
94,000 is is that in excess of the
diesel costs that are already um being
spent
yes I can confirm that that was the the
sort of um approximate cost at the time
yes that's correct say it's an excess of
so the fuel bill is around about 300,000
so it's an excess of that at the
time counc
SP thank you chairman um Mr H you You'
highlighted the disparity between
various offices in central government
our uh supplier or use seller of waste
facilities Norse have on hands
information across the country what is
their findings on this issue regarding
the uh the diesel thank
you thank you C sping so I me I mean
obviously I think they've looked at more
how whether it's actually um suitable to
run the fleet and so I think they
they're quite content with how it runs
in terms of of purchasing so I think
they're running their Fleet up in North
Hans if I remember correctly uh on
biodiesel and so they'll say that that
uh in operative terms as Council cross
has already alluded that you know
there's no reason why diesel engines
cannot run on biodiesel perfectly well
but in terms of Providence I think again
I don't think that's something they've
looked into in any depth to be quite
honest I think just said it's something
that was requested by their client there
at the time they're quite happy to to
undertake thank
you councel ho do you want to reply to
council fd's comments earlier I'm sorry
I sort of skipped through without
um so I think that was probably more of
a question for the
officer than me regarding the the
changes and I think um counc newort
indicated to speak as
well can nort
thank you chairman um through you chair
if um to
um um Henry mus I was quite interested
to hear about the Bol purchase project
through a seller but could um the
officer tell us how long that project
will take to perhaps come to fruition um
so we can see if if that would work so
for when we're setting our budgets
thanks thanks councelor Newport um this
project is live we're collecting data
literally the emails went out yesterday
it's part of the working group for
seller the environment sustainability
work Stream So once we've got a full
idea of what the volumes are which we
know are going to be about 1.2 million
because the districts are similar size
two to 250,000 liters per District the
next stage will we just go to the three
main suppliers which have the best
Provence because there is issues around
the Providence due to Chinese Imports
Germany at the moment is questioning it
and it's quite a fragile system so
unless we can absolutely sort this
Providence out then the reputational
risk is too high so we we're going we're
going along with the the process as as
as we alluded to Def for Department
saying yes and environment eny saying no
so as long as we can nail down the
Providence the bulk buying purchase
procurement exercise is taking place now
so within a month we'll get an idea from
a supply what that price would come down
to but it's a difference between 250,000
liters versus something like 1.2 million
l
so that should get a discount um and
then we look at strategic use of
depos um between the the six
you sorry if I may chairman just come
back on these questions in the next and
I
don't marus hton wants to answer
council's question for me I'll be
grateful however I point out a lot of
these questions around the hydrogenated
vegetable oil are things that the
committee will be looking at in the next
few months this is why we have put the
report back from October to a later
meeting probably early next year
so what we're talking about opening this
meeting hasn't yet been considered by
the committee but will be considered by
the committee in the next few months
thank
you well members I mean I think there's
been a really informative discussion and
I thank the officers for um their input
it seems very interesting far about my
pay grade so oh we got hand up again
okay you wish to speak before I finish
this be the last
one um page
7.1.1 one of the aims of this
Administration is to maximize
opportunities for renewable energies
generated in the district I just
wondered isn't this into
contradiction with their members of this
Administration that um voted against the
recent application for a solar farm
in
ra where is the commitment to
[Music]
this um I don't feel able to comment on
an application that's currently um has
is in
appeal thank you I think we've we've
hammered this quite well and I think
it's' been extremely informative and I
look forward to the next report not but
uh anyway we'll now move on then so
we're now going to item eight update of
the work of the planning policy
committee and I now invite councelor Jim
Crips to introduce his
report thank you Mr chairman good
evening members I'm tbling this um for
noting it's a narrative
document uh so I'm not going to read it
for bating um I thought I'd rather give
you an overall View to go with the
report since we restarted as the
planning policy commission we've had
four planning policy committee meetings
two of them have been
conventional uh meetings the other two
have been three-hour Workshop type of
meetings um we have covered a lot of
ground in that time as this report uh
shows and the headlin summ it up local
development scheme was considered
speciaal options Fe feedback from the
consultation was considered Brownfield
register was updated local plan strategy
was gone through then we moved on to
some more recently to evidence-based
subjects like the economic development
need assessment and the employment land
needs review there are still others to
do so the next uh planning policy
meeting is now set for the 14th of
November and we will move on to cover a
number of items the main item uh which
will be the rump of that particular
meeting is coming up with the codes and
master plan um very important document
and a big document uh because this will
set the policy for Downstream
development committee basis for
approving applications and so on it goes
through the code
and it's quite complex and it has
changed quite some because the in
October we saw new building regulations
coming through and there are a number of
issues uh on there that got to be
modified um for example any home built
with a drive is going to have to have an
electric charging point on that on that
drive uh that's typically one of the uh
Greener items that they're bringing in U
so we've got to get ah around that as
well so the rump of that meeting will go
for that there are others behind it that
we will be working in parallel with um
and that will be Heritage in Impact
assessment Town Hall Center uh Town
Center health check and local cycling
and walking uh which we're also striving
to get through um in the next session
but the rump will be the very important
codes and policies that we're going to
go for um
[Music]
in parallel with that of course um work
elsewhere with
Consultants is well and truly underway
now and we will start seeing the results
of those coming in in November and we
will then move on to look at the the key
key consultant documents uh transport
assessment and the infrastructure
delivery aspect of it which is the key
documents which will um either
be easy simple or they're going to cause
a bit of recycle and reiteration U to
accommodate them and get the best deal
from that so we are going forward uh the
14th is the next stop and there'll be
another meeting after that but we'll
figure that out when we see how far
we've got in the 14th meeting so I'd
like you to consider this consider
noting this report which I'm putting
forward on behalf of the director of
place
thank
you Mrs Ming you wish to ask a
question yes uh thank you chair and
thank you councilor Crips um the
difficulties of compiling an acceptable
local plan a
legendary it is a diversive and complex
situation and I'm sure that any members
here that have been through the process
before will understand how difficult
this work is and I would like to
congratulate councilor Crips on the work
he's done as a new member to the council
and I think he he's done excellent work
so far and I would like that acknowledge
thank
you councelor
ward thank you
chairman um there's a couple questions
I'd like to ask you know try to be as
constructive as possible in regards to
the local plan it's a extremely
difficult plan to actually come into
fruition and one of the things that I I
am still concerned about are the
Brownfield sites basically uh if I may
say as a portfolio holder for strategic
planning in the last Administration I
brought forward a policy to look at
Brownfield par Brownfield and
contaminated sites and bring them
forward as a priority before Green Belt
which I think is something that many of
our residents want to see so all I would
like to know is our is the leader and
members of his administration committed
to looking at the Brownfield
sites in in the hle and be looking
forward to bring them forward as a
priority in this next local plan and I
do have a supplementary as well
chairman councelor C can you s yeah yes
thank you councelor ward um as we
discussed at the last meeting on this
particular subject uh we're hind bound
Lock Stock and Barrel to the
mppf uh program uh policy and that makes
it very clear that Brownfield needs to
be optimized maximized um there are I
suggest hundreds of paragraphs in the in
the Imp PF document um picking one out
to give it some sort of blessing um we
didn't see was worthwhile um we are
committed to it the mppf forces us to be
committed to it and we are and we will
be committed to it it's already been
discussed at length this subject in fact
um we've reiterated it ourselves twice
already um so I'd like to assure
councilor W that I'm Pro Grandfield and
wherever possible wherever legal and
wherever allowable we will pursue that
that rout thank you can W your
supplementary thank you very much
chairman um I would like to draw the
attention then on item 8 uh page
84 uh item 1.16 and just for the sake of
people not being able to get to it
quickly enough a core task at the heart
of advancing the new local plan is
setting the plan strategy in Practical
terms this has meant beginning a process
of shortlisting options for both the
plan strategy and as an example how
development is distributed and phased
and individual development sites now
this brings me on to the next point
which I I hope will be treated as
constructive um
would the leader
give an undertaking to cons to instruct
planning officers responsible for
planning that they contact all
interested parties that may have
ownership interests with Brownfield Park
Brownfield and contaminated sites and
invite them to a free prea meeting to
establish if their site can be brought
forward for development as this would
give a clear indic ation to residents of
land being brought forward under
consideration and and I think it's
actually a very
constructive um point I'm making in as
much that it will help us to develop the
local plan strategy by actually
understanding those Brownfield sites
that can actually be developed rather
than just guessing at them for what
we've got thank you chairman ccor
Crips
there was a big gap between the previous
uh planning policy committee
meeting uh to the first one that I
called when I took on the position that
was a an 11 11 month gap between
planning policy committee
meetings this subject had had plenty of
time to be aired but despite that it was
brought up again in one of our formal
meeting and I accepted going back to
revisit
it regenerate it go through it and the
officers produced a report on
it that was brought back to the second
meeting so we've been through
this a numerous times the criteria is
very complex for a Brownfield site
that's been discussed at nauseum about
what doesn't doesn't qualify and there
are numerous aspects to it I believe
this subjects had more than enough
attention and I've just previously a few
minutes ago committed to optimizing
Brownfield SS we're committed to do that
we have a schedule now which is not
insignificant and we're going to try and
make those work and if sites on there
make the cut with the nppf rules then
they will make it through if they don't
they won't make it through so this
covers I think that point we're not
going to go out literally knocking on
people's doors to ask them if the their
bit of land is for sale which was one
suggestion that came
up I think we've done more than enough
uh to satisfy the the needs of the mppf
on
Brownfield councelor
Foster thank you Mr chairman um the
question I'm most asked by
residents and for that matter by
colleagues as well is what's happening
about the allocation of sites for future
Housing
Development particular question is from
a resident group deeply concerned about
a site which they know was put forward
by the landowner in
2021 spatial option
consultation which in itself of course
is part of tonight's report and largely
I would dare say a repeat of earlier
reports the next steps part of tonight's
report is lacking a clear picture of the
next steps and a timetable to achieve
the completion of the next local plan in
time for the 20125 Target so I would
suggest there be an all member briefing
and a report which can be shared with
residents explaining where we are and a
timetable of next steps to achieve
completion of the
plan I should
that I'm very well aware that the
preparation of the plan is a huge task
and I know that Council of Crips has
driven a great deal of work on that
subject in to go with a
position I note also that tonight's
report is the report of the director of
place but signed by the Strategic team
uh policy team leader I have the
greatest respect for the tremendous work
being done by the Strategic policy team
leader and the main officer supporting
him in the development of the plan but
but I wonder whether there is sufficient
resource supporting them and whether the
departure of the current director will
weaken that
support I've got a three-pronged remit
none of which is human
resources so I believe I have to defer
that question and I would imagine that
has to go to the
CEO
[Music]
thank you chairman and thank you
councelor Foster and councelor Crips um
with regards to resources we review
regular resources um people do leave the
organization as you're aware you've just
referenced the director who is leaving
at the end of the year um at the moment
we're undertaking a recruitment process
but also we're looking at the gaps in
resource required to fulfill some of the
Ambitions of this Council so that is a
regular conversation there is a meeting
set up with councelor Crips and officers
to talk through that and to reassure him
and and
and then future further me members of
the resource required um so that is
happening the next couple of weeks so we
can report back um if that's the case
but I'm I'm confident we've got the
resource and we've got a process in
place to ensure we've got intering
Resource as
well councelor Mrs
mcferson thank you chairman um my
questions on uh page 8.4
1.17 um it states a a workshop involving
members of the planning policy committee
um has been held to consider what may
form appropriate sifting criteria to
help begin the process of shortlisting
options it then goes on to list th that
criteria uh my question
is uh what will um the first one is in
Rel relation to the conflict with areas
of heightened flood risk so my question
is what will this be assessed by
and will it include forecasting taking
into account climate change as somewhere
near a flood zone in a few years time
May well be in a flood
zone thank
you
[Music]
can uh the tend of 1.17 says includes
criteria such as and then it gives us
some examples and you'll notice that the
uh conflict with areas of tight and
flood GS is top of the list uh on on
there um
we have sets of tests that have to be
done uh as part of the local plan and
the planning function um that they have
to be guided by but we are looking here
to avoid Category 3 Category 2
classifications that was what was
discussed and minuted in the meeting
that that we had um
and I take your point about uh how
serious this is I've been actively
involved for a year now on flooding in
rorth uh so I do appreciate the problem
um but we have acknowledged that we're
trying to choose sites that are free of
that sort of uh problem um and that is
part of the selection process but what
we're doing at the moment by the
transport uh assessment we're
postulating where you could put stuff
and testing it against that until we've
gone through that reiteration and
started to identify the areas that are
best served in all respects then we'll
have some shape to that uh but we will
be taking that aspect very seriously
because I'm committed to it councel M
mcf you ever your subsequent mention
thank you chairman uh councelor Crips I
do not envy your role at all but what I
will say is you didn't actually answer
my question you're taking into
consideration flood zones two and three
in this local plan okay this local plan
that you're putting forward for
2025 what I would like to see in there
is a forecast because there's areas
outside of those flood zone areas that
will be two and three come 2026 or
2027 so I'm asking you a straight
question will you be forecasting and
taking into account climate change and
how those areas neighboring zones two
and three could be in a flood zone two
and three in years to come in the not so
distant future thank you coun grips you
wish to
reply dur during the uh
early stages of documentation the floods
onone risk assessment from the
environmental agency was at stage one
there's two more stages for that to go
through not this year stage two will
fall into into into next year I've read
the first one uh which is very big um
but they do take into account the the
global warming tide rise predicted Tide
Rises and so on and they simulate that
on on the maps that they're putting
forward and it's very clear to me
because close to my heart is roris where
I've been trying to do flood defenses
for some time now um and I've looked at
that model and other models on there and
it does emphasize the problem and so as
far as I'm concerned if that emphasizes
a problem in a Zone Beyond three and two
by one because it's so close to it it's
going to become a problem I will be
flagging that up and I certainly won't
be Sur
thank you chairman councelor H you wish
to speak uh no longer chairman thank you
cast Mill uh thank you chairman i' just
like to ask councelor Crips um paragraph
1.15 on page 8.4 you mention in the
report that the Brownfield register will
be shortly published with an interactive
map have you got an indication of how
long shortly
is avable it's already available yeah
well that's good is there an intention
or or is there going to be a wording
with it as the residents can you use the
mic please we can't hear problem as as
the residents will see the interactive
map as will land owners are we going to
invite anyone who's got observations in
that to get in touch with the council
because that way we could uh collect
other sites possibly and also so the can
the N the residents themselves will get
a good idea how that relates to their
own properties and so on and that's just
my question if you're going to do that
on the website thank
you okay the the interactive map was on
the back of the written report and is
available I will I actually haven't I'll
be honest I haven't actually physically
looked at it since that was written um I
will look at it and make it available to
uh uh well I'll do a note to everybody
and tell you where the link is for the
access to it and that way every
counselor can get to it if they want to
but it's uh it's done I've seen it done
I just haven't checked it gone in online
to check it myself I will do that and
get it out to everybody I'll just copy
it to every member thank you very much
thank you councilor W you've had quite a
few questions I'll give you this one
more it has to be related to this all
right thank you chairman it's it's
basically just a continuation of res
actually I I do empathize with counselor
Crips and what he's got to do I really
have I do understand having been there
um I think going back to
201120 when the core strategy was being
envisaged and came into fruition there
were eight policy planners working on
that um and I know how many are working
on it now and it certainly isn't eight
um I'm going to guess I'm going to ask
uh the leader as far as act concerned
also through to the CEO regard to
Resource because in my mind over the
years I've been involved the resource is
certainly insufficient thank
you thank you right members I think
we've knocked this to death now and um
and I see a big future for further
reports so we're going to move on now
and we're now on to item Nine Business
from last
standby
sorry I'm jumping the gun counc Crips
did you want take the opportunity to
reply to that or or councelor Hoy
whoever wants
to no okay I get cward point
Sorry I'm I'm a new boy as you can see
I'm quite happy for Council to make that
comment okay you Council
thank you chairman
um councilor Crips has ay answered the
questions that have been put um as
regards resourcing um he drew to my
attention the level of resourcing as
might be affected by um people leading
the
organization my first um intention was
to say to him yes I'm concerned about
resourcing I'm concerned about the plan
and there is a plan there's a very
detailed plan which is held by the
offices which I know councelor Crips has
and I believe it will have been shared
uh in an appropriate form with planning
policy the purpose of me standing now is
to say to you that I've invited
councelor Crips to speak and have a
meeting with the director of place the
team leader for planning policy and the
chief executive to look at that plan and
ensure that um there is resourcing if
the plan is to be unaltered and if there
isn't resourcing then the plan is Reed
with reference to that committee thank
you
chairman thank you Council Mason now
members uh due to a request I'm going to
have a five minute recess for comfort
and then I'd like you to get back here
as soon as possible so I'm just going to
Jour for 5 minutes thank
you
e
let me see if we can start taking our
seats
[Music]
please
thank you members we'll now commence and
carry on with the meeting we're now
moving to item Nine Business from the
last council meeting sorry chair we need
to note those that last
item sorry who
was I believe we need to note though the
last
item
I don't think that was an item worth not
I know Mr cast said it for noting
but it wasn't down as a noted item so
just for information if you're all
noting it then I'm fine I'll take it as
noted if you're happy to note
it that's what I mean see friendship
good lovely but item nine Vis from last
council meeting members are there any
questions relating to the business of
the last council
meeting there are none item 10 report
and urg decisions there are
none item 11 report of the leader on the
work of the executives members I would
now invite councelor John Mason to
present the leader's
report thank you thank you chairman um
you've heard from two of the uh lead
members at length uh this evening so I
won't repeat any of the work that
they've been doing
um I'd like to just just run through the
things that the executive are going to
be dealing with over the next few weeks
um I'll start with the reports of to the
executive committee on the 16th of
November and we have three
reports maybe another coming forward um
skateboard facilities two skateboard
facilities are are being recommended um
by councelor Julie Gooding and by Mr
hotton and they they will be coming
forward for
approval we have the Q2 budget
monitoring report from the director of
resources and I have one recommendation
presently from the on that met in
October but 's meeting on the 2nd of
November so I need to June June note
that reports coming to for Council on
the 14th of
December there's going to be an officer
report on the annual reviews of exempt
items this is a this is something that's
required upon the monitoring officer in
the Constitution and it's never been
brought to council so I'm asking it to
come to council to
conduct the current Year's review and
whatever number of additional reviews
the monitoring officer can build in in
the time
frame
further at the full Council
in
December the lead member for finance
Council Hoy will be bringing forward a
review of fees and charges for
instead of bringing it Forward at the
same time as the
budget lead members have held a number
of fact-f finding discussions with
officers over the last few
weeks councel Julie Gooding has been
talking
to the manager of open spaces and the
director Mr hotton about 3G pitches
we have been meeting to have a briefing
on the uh next round of the grant
funding under the UK shared Prosperity
fund doing it early as we can so that we
can consider um the structure that's
already been set to
consider potential projects that can fit
within it call for further ones and
ultimately ly meet with the the Rochford
partnership and a report to comes to the
executive in
January the lead member again Council
Hoy um adjust also assisted by councilor
James
Newport has brought forward discussions
um and fact finding on business
improvement district opportunities
otherwise known as
bids and something which goes under a a
terrible name which is under Council
crys is something called the LC Whip and
you you may all look around wondering
just what that is I can tell you it is
local cycling and walking infrastructure
plans and it's about unlocking
government and active travel England
funding with ethics County Council there
was a lot of fact findinding in that in
particular particular potentially
looking at at Roots as um as currently
drafted consultations there's a number
of consultations going on at present
there is a consultation on the new
Leisure contract with residents and
you've seen how it's been promoted
across the district and also SLC
Consultants are currently working with
stakeholders on both the feasibility and
the procurement streams of the of the
project Council Hoy has put forward and
we are currently running a budget survey
with
residents in addition we all enjoyed
those who could make it we all enjoyed
the members budget
workshop and we will process process
from there that completes my review of
what the executive are going to to be
doing over the next few weeks thank you
chairman thank you Council
Mason members we look at item 12 agenda
item 12 notice motions on notice members
you will be aware item 12 has been
withdrawn by Council arine sha and so
members this concludes the business for
the for this meeting and thank you all
for attending on our clear the meeting
close at
953 thank you 853
[Music]
apologies members please be upstanding
while the chairman counselor Jack
laurman and the chief executive Jonathan
Stevenson retire from the
meeting